why would anybody watch a scum show like
Videodrome
why did you watch it max business
reasons sure what about the other
reasons all right it's time for another
movie review yeah this is a Kronberg
Flay yes and I don't want to do one for
a long time I actually want to do dead
ringers too because this movie and Dead
Ringers are my two favorite corner bar
movies oh no I think this one in the
brood yeah well the brew Videodrome all
the Cronenberg's movies are good and
I've seen them all except for Fast
Company which was his action movie that
came out in 1979 which I've heard it's
not that great but I've seen all of his
other ones and all of his other ones are
awesome like I don't think he's made a
bad movie
one of the best things about Cronenberg
is that he's connected to John Carpenter
they were buddies yeah and then John
Carpenter was buddies with the crustle
so there's like this crustle connection
a synergy yeah well yeah I like Flash
Gordon because Flash Gordon was almost
played by the crustle okay did you know
that so it's like six degrees of crustal
cross connected with all the movies that
I like maybe the crustle is like the
secret of the whole universe yeah he's
in there yeah it's kind of like
zero-point energy there's something
called crossover point he's at the cross
the entire yes exactly
[Laughter]
okay so anyway today we are talking
about the classic David Cronenberg film
Videodrome from 1983 yeah now
interestingly this movie and this came
out after Stanners yes scanners was
actually a pretty big hit yeah because
you know scanners is kind of a more
straightforward horror movie everybody
loves the exploding heads
I mean you see I saw these back when
they came out yeah I saw skaters at the
drive-in yo yeah
12 and 13 and we're coming out on
Cinemax and they were almost they had
like this illicit feel to them
yeah every kid you had to stay up late
to watch oh yeah and maybe you really
didn't want to get caught by your mom
you know I mean watching the [ __ ] yeah
cuz then they say no you can't watch
those yeah yeah well I mean especially
Cronenberg's early films are very seedy
yeah and per se and I think videos are
kind of like the apex of the seediness
yeah the way they're shot you know they
made you feel very disoriented yeah and
you're you weren't really sure what the
movie was about first thing when you
were younger you're like wow is this
really happening to this guy or is he
tripping yeah what's this director
trying to tell me and there's something
just that the way they were shot there
was kind of a cheapness to the feel
which kind of made it more scary and it
wasn't so cheap to wear you know and you
no longer believed it like you know they
had some cheap horror movies and like
yeah this one this one was right at the
edge the quality level you know and it
was a serious movie yeah you know but it
wasn't the full-blown Hollywood
production style movie this is something
that really you weren't supposed to be
seeing that's that's kind of how that's
how it felt it does have that vibe to it
right and like the coolest thing about
Cronenberg one of the coolest things
about Cronenberg is that he makes very
intellectual cerebral type of horror
movies they're almost kind of like I
want to use the word anthropological you
know I mean they're very like detached
right in the same way in a similar way
as Kubrick's films are that they're kind
of detached from the story but then on
the other hand they're very visceral
diversionary and they're very concerned
with like people's insides manifesting
themselves on the outside and like the
merging of biology with technology that
kind of thing that's kind of a disease
that's one of the really big theme
Kubrick was he was good to his like you
know The Shining of course it was one of
our first episodes that we did on 13
o'clock you know we talked about that
yeah but who Kubrick was kind of
highbrow yeah Oldenburg was kind of
lowbrow in a certain way well he's kind
of the thing
lowbrow kubrick in a way yeah it would
do things that Kubrick wouldn't say no
I'm not gonna do that yeah although I
would argue to that Cronenberg is
actually highbrow but lowbrow at the
same time and that's hard to pull off
right and so like if you can find a
director that does cuz I'm into that I
like that aesthetic that's like really
smart but also really kind of yucky and
yeah disturbing and there's not a lot of
directors that do that type of [ __ ] yeah
and I was and you know carpenter he
liked Cronenberg yes he actually named
characters Cronenberg yeah in his movies
yeah honor no they were they were gross
yeah you know but I would have to say
that probably Cronenberg was a little
more consistent then carpenter then
Carper yeah carpenter about probably
about 75 80 percent of his movies were
good and then some of them were just
like carpenter was better when he was
young and independent yeah when he
started getting involved with studios
and went you know in the big trying to
make big bucks and he's you know dealing
with Hollywood directly and especially
after he got a little bit older I think
he was just trying to knock movies out
yeah this was not yeah I mean the
interesting thing about Cronenberg oh
well the interesting thing about
Videodrome is that Videodrome was
actually he had made several movies
before that shivers you know which was
also very good about a sexually
transmitted disease or like a parasite
yeah yeah that was a good movie to get
that and you know he made rabid - I
think before Videodrome and Videodrome
was his first film that was distributed
by a major Hollywood studio and it was
because it was on the back of the
successive scanners and other
independent movies that he had done that
Universal said that they would
distribute this movie now he had never
really dealt with the Hollywood system
before so he had never had to go through
like test screenings and stuff like that
now in video drum was screen test screen
for audiences they hated it they didn't
get it right in you know I mean but it
was a shorter version of the one that we
it was yeah because that's something
the Cronenberg is very and he will say
this himself that he is a ruthless
editor and that sometimes he takes too
much out so that the story is like
incomprehensible to the guy you know
what I mean and a lot of times and also
in the case of Videodrome this script
was actually not finished when they
started working on it
well I think one of the things that
Cronenberg did is that he kind of made
[ __ ] up as he as he went along
yeah which that's good because he had a
bunch of different possible plot lines
that he'd be working at once and it kind
of helped to the feeling of kind of
alienation that you got when you saw it
yeah weren't really but you know what it
added to the visceral nature of it
things were spontaneous you could tell
because because this story was evolving
he was evolving as he was going the same
way so it was almost like a meta like a
like it was almost commenting on itself
yeah well he try something out in the
movie he's a tall man I really like that
you know I thought of something let's go
this way
yeah yeah no listen this is the steer
the story towards this direction yeah
and you don't really you can't really
feel it when you don't know that yeah
but when you're told that you go back
and watch it oh yeah I see what I did
that yeah yeah you had actually written
three different endings for a Videodrome
and didn't really decide which one to
use until the end and some people have
argued they didn't really like the
ending as much but I think the ending
was actually pretty spot-on so I don't
know what the other two possibilities
yeah I don't either so it's kind of hard
for me to say because look maybe with
the other one I know one of them and one
of them he commits suicide and ends up
on the floor the showroom floor of
Videodrome clay we're having merging sex
with Deborah here who is the other one
oh the woman that ran Bianca the alien
yeah Bianca oblivion yeah he'll kind of
merged in together in some kind of weird
sexual union and they were all part of
the new flesh which he had to understand
when you know they were morphing yeah so
it'd have been kind of like kind of like
the scene out of the thing yeah where
you have switch between between this and
the thing probably had the best special
effects of any movies at that time and
the Rick Baker did the effects for this
one he did them in two months yeah and
actually they still look pretty damn
good yeah and a funny thing is that the
Videodrome was shot in an insanely short
period of time that was not within 90
days yeah you know and it had to do with
Canadian taxes yeah like a tax law they
had like it you know at the end of the
year from September to December there'd
be you know businessmen looking to do an
investment in a movie but you had to do
all the principal photography yeah
between September and December you could
do like post-production and [ __ ] like
that after that but to get the money you
had to make the movie all to put all the
you know main principle photography had
to be done
so Adrian said I burn doesn't matter
Berg found an angle and of course and
that was the angle that he used I'd have
done the same thing yeah oh yeah you got
a lot of movies make that way sure now
the cool thing about Videodrome and I
think one of the reasons that it's one
of my favorite movies of his and
actually I think it's kind of the
epitome of the Cronenberg movie it's the
most Cronenberg Ian I guess you can say
of all the Cronenberg movies yeah II
know before it's gonna this is a bizarre
movie people it is maybe this is what
you it's very ahead of its time way
ahead of its time and it's not so
bizarre that it becomes nonsensical like
there there's certain aspects of say
Eraserhead that there's just so surreal
you're you know you can't really grasp
but I cannot dummy like me well I mean
well David Lynch movies you need to see
them several times right like before the
narrative becomes clear to you
Videodrome is a bizarre movie that that
makes sense yeah you can understand it
basically on the first in the kitchen
under sound to every element right but
but you know on multiple viewings you go
get suited up yeah and the cool thing
about video drove to is that like I said
it's a very intellectual exercise like
it has a lot of like philosophical
things to say about media and identity
and in technology replacing human
relationships and things like that and
you can enjoy it on that level but you
can also enjoy just kind of as a gross
yeah weird like horror slash sci-fi is
it even a sci-fi movie I guess I kind of
is I don't know what it's not really not
a viable in that way
no the premise of the story is a guy who
owns a cheap television station is
trying to find the best softcore
horn that he can he can put on there he
dealt with the Japanese and he bought a
series but he wasn't all that yeah he's
looking for something edgier right and
one of his technical guys finds a
clandestine signal that he thinks is
coming from Malaysia yeah via satellite
and it basically just its ongoing murder
they basically just bring people in to a
ready to play a room it's called a
torture them and yell them called
Videodrome
at first they don't know that it's real
snuff they don't run that out till later
alright they just think it's someone
faking it and it's not there's no sex in
it it's just torture murder in a wet
room the walls are electrified I think
they thought it was yeah some of the
walls were electrified I remember seeing
it looks realistic yeah and on the
version that I have is I have the with
the criteria we got a criterion when
they have a hall of the torture scenes
that were cut out yeah because they
actually filmed you know a lot more than
they showed in the movie and how its
shown to you as an observer is there in
a television studio trying to dial in on
this signal and you're seeing it on
television you're never really there in
that you don't I mean as as ever you
never in there you so it's kind of
creepy you're watching the movie where
they're looking at a television screen
go look at that and then that's how you
see that yeah so really it kind of
immerses you in the story in that way
because especially for people our age
that were kind of coming of age in the
early 80s you know when home video was
just you know getting coming into its
own and getting really popular and you
know sometimes you would get like pay
channels or you get and you would see
like illicit stuff that you want
supposed to see cuz any is scrambling
and stuff yeah because they used to do
scrambling and like the Playboy channel
another there
yeah you'd like try to zoom look I think
it's your boobs yeah they're trying to
unscramble this signal and you see it
you know and it's only on for like a
short period of time the guy tells my
can only pick it up for like I think was
it 20-30 minutes at a time seconds
seconds a few seconds that's right and
anyway what's the weirdest part about it
is that the guy who runs the the
television studio it's like yeah I want
that on my channel yeah no that's like a
reaction to that you know she's Woods
plays max red and he's like the head of
it's kind of like a UHF station I guess
they never really get into it they never
really get into it but you know it's its
whole mission is to show like basically
just sleaze TV yeah softcore porn
violent stuff like that you could not
show on broadcast television in some way
I thought it might have been cable
because I think what the because
honestly I've always seen this movie as
a satire obedience at time yeah and I
think that he's all Cronenberg is almost
operating in an alternate Toronto
because that's where it's said where
this channel could exist okay you know
what I guess the only expert because
they don't really comment on it like
we're not allowed to show that or mean
they just do they just show porn and
they show like violence on TV and it's
fine
like no one really says anything right
now near the beginning of the movie max
Renn is on a talk show and that's where
he meets Nicki brand who's Debbie
Carey's character and really this this
scene is kind of like the fulcrum of the
whole theme of the movie which yet it's
really cool cuz there's a television on
set with them yeah with a guy talking
his name's Brian oblivion yeah he's like
a philosopher yes really cool and he's
the one that actually came up with video
drama it's that a minute the whole theme
of the movie is and like I said this is
Cronenberg I don't think he's commenting
like coming down on one side or another
but that's the cool thing about
Cronenberg movies is they don't really
have a message per se he's just
observing yeah and what he's commenting
on particularly in the early 80s when
this movie came out and like I said with
the whole home video boom and stuff like
that there was a lot of controversy over
whether seeing porn or seeing these like
horribly violent slasher movies would
affect people's behavior particularly in
the UK with the whole video nasty scare
and stuff like that which I actually you
know there was a very right-wing
government and at the time and they were
saying we should ban these movies or we
should cut all this stuff out and there
was a huge thing about it in the u.s.
you know of course you had the satanic
panic go on yeah similar kind of thing
yeah the US was more focused on music
yeah they're worried about what kind of
music I mean it was hard but there was a
movie yeah yeah movies also but I think
in the u.s. I mostly manifested itself
as the satanic panic they were trying on
down yeah but it was a similar yeah and
I think that Cronenberg wanted to
comment on what if like all of these
moral guardians that think we should cut
these movies and stuff like that
what if everything they said was true
what if these watching these images did
[ __ ] you up in a literal way like it
gave you a brain tumor right and they
killed you like what if that was
literally true like I said I don't think
that he agrees with that but I think
he's like making a like almost like a
black comedy
yeah like commenting on that there was
an idea there was another subtext to
laid underneath that he was also
commenting that many of the things
people believe many of the opinions
people have they actually got from
television yes all right
so the media is actually manipulating
people yeah and like I said he takes
that in a very literal sense what
happens
Videodrome the television show in some
ways it's almost it's almost like an
afterthought because it turns out later
that the signal that's under the
underlying Videodrome that gives people
tumors and gives them hallucinations and
stuff like that yeah actually does not
have to be put under that show it
doesn't put under anything yeah we put
our tiny pattern they can put it or
anything kind of kind of getting ahead
though of what happens he gets exposed
to Videodrome and real rapidly he starts
having these weird hallucinations but
they don't the cool thing is that they
don't mark when the middle age starts
everything is
exactly the same so you don't know
what's a hallucination and what is not
and and the main character is in every
scene in this movie so you're seeing
reality from his point of view yeah
everything is sure when the
hallucinations start no and he ends up
trying to make contact with the people
who make Videodrome cuz he wants to buy
him one on his channel and this leads
him into a lot of trouble like you know
he is pornographer friend is like no you
do not want to mess with those people
that make Videodrome because what
there's a philosophy behind that
yeah which leads them to this like this
mission called the cathode Witek oh look
at that
ray mission a cathode ray mission and it
looks like a church and they're bringing
in the nation's homeless and its poor
and they're solving the nation's
problems by making them watch television
yeah that's some weird [ __ ] well because
the whole thing Brian oblivion who like
I said is kind of you only see him on TV
screens yeah and you find out later on
in the movie that he's actually dead but
that he he lives on like a video through
these videos that his daughter Bianca
has been you know he's here late and he
any question you ask him there's enough
videotapes they can splice together to
make a video and he will answer your
question that way yeah and he only
speaks in monologue and he only applaud
as his preferred media yeah and then he
only appears on the cathode ray tube and
the cathode ray tube is an extension of
the human mind and that it's part of you
and it's really it was actually very its
time and it's comment on how much
technology and media has affected our
lives and that the television screen is
part of your body yeah that's weird
that's one of your sensory organs right
and he's making that literal so Brian
oblivion he was the one that kind of
accidentally came upon this the
Videodrome signal and initially he
wanted to use it for the betterment of
mankind he wanted to pretty much plug
everyone into like a great human
conscious yeah I guess was his and what
they all what they're doing this is an
80s foreshadowing of the Internet
yeah basically what they're talking
yeah there they're saying that you know
the Cronenberg is saying that well video
in a way in video rental why and cable
TV is it kind of the prototype Internet
yeah is that right
everyone can get the same opinions of
life through video yeah and many goes on
he says eventually we each one of us
will have our own special names that we
will use on the screen yeah it's all
about screen names yeah of course it's
pretty cool and like I said you really
forced saw like a lot of the whole you
know image over substance or or people's
entire lives being conducted online like
without any physical contact and things
like that so like I said very ahead of
its time right and they're telling you
to give up your body so you can just
become the world of video live on
forever yeah that'll like transhumanism
yeah you can give up your body and
download your consciousness into them
into the web and live on inside the
internet right which that might be
possible yeah one day so like I said you
know though it was a waiting prescient
wait but this movie was yeah but so the
thing is so Brian oblivion like I said
he actually thought it could be used for
good but after he died the other guy who
helped him find it who was Barry convex
was the bad guy under the guise of his
spectacular optical company you know we
make we make cheap glasses for the third
world and weapons systems or whatever so
he kind of stole the technology now what
he wanted to do was use Videodrome to
give tumors and kill people who were
scumbags enough to watch Videodrome
right yeah so you're kind of like so so
he was kind of like mechanism moral
purity a moral purity like he's saying
if you're enough of a sleaze come and
watch this then you deserve to die and
this is literally gonna K and they were
gonna use the symbol they were gonna use
the signal to toughen up first world
people because the third world enemies
were tougher than they yeah so does that
is to toughen people up and make up
soldiers yeah and in the end what they
end up doing because they wanted to so
they end up using max
when essentially as an assassin to kind
of because they want to kind of test out
the signal and see if it works
and so they are generally very literally
manipulating his brain yeah
and this happens in a series of very
like kind of gross kind of [ __ ] where
like you know James Woods he develops
that vaginal what it is stomach yeah and
you know they puts it they put the tapes
in it and it's almost like they're
programming this is where video drum
gets weird and weird from the very
beginning it is a weird movie yeah
there's no real way to know as a viewer
whether or not we are seeing Husa
nations or has this technology really
allowed people to modify their own body
right because the guy starts to become
something kind of like out of the thing
he can actually make someone else's fist
become a bomb and once yeah and blow him
up did he hallucinate that or didn't he
really do that or did that really yeah
you don't really know we also put a
pistol inside his own body and then
later took that pistol out and it merged
then where its gentleman's hand into a
stance of his hand was a pistol and he's
gone long live the new flesh and all
this there's a very Christian motif to
some of this stuff yeah that's going on
about you know rebirth and rebirth and
you know the spirits like I like the
Spirit of the Lord but yeah I can't
remember exactly how he termed it it's
bizarre flu yeah it was like a rebirth
in a non non physical form is what
you're us basically doing I think I
think what was going on this is the very
maybe Cronenberg had heard about
prototypes of the internet because they
existed at that time
yeah the 70s they did so maybe he was
imagining where television and the
Internet were merged and people could
merge and with that yeah so I think
Videodrome really looking back on it I
think it was Cronenberg's imagination
this dude's got a hell of imagination oh
yeah he was imagining transhumanism and
he was imagining internet and how a
person could go inside the Internet
physically by downloading your
consciousness right to it it was just
the video which was the technology at
the time just
yeah the technology but it could be
interpreted as Internet - yeah he was
interpreting in kind of horror type
fashion or Internet and like I said okay
and another cool thing about all of
Colonel Burke's movies but this one in
particular is that the main character of
max Renn played by James Woods is a
scumbag I mean he's a scumbag doesn't
believe in anything yes
you know I mean even after he finds out
that Videodrome is actual snuff he wants
it yeah okay yeah I'm gonna put that on
- yeah and the reason you know the fact
that he had no principles was the reason
that he was manipulated so easily by
both sides of the the inventors of video
drum and was able to be manipulated but
the cool thing about it though is that
Cronenberg does not judge him no he's
still a likable character he's likable
he's relatable even though he's a sleaze
yeah you still kind of empathize with
that well I think I think he symbolizes
your average like TV television snob
yeah doesn't really have opinions of his
own yeah he's just getting his opinions
based on what he's being told what be
shown on television yeah that's who
that's who the name no way it's like
it's almost you know as detached as the
movie is his performance is very nuanced
you know what I mean yeah it's like he's
he's still a very likable character and
like I said
Cronenberg doesn't really comment on you
know whether any of this is good or bad
it's not just he's just observing and he
did the same thing in shivers about the
sexual parasite where everyone was kind
of turning into these sex fiends and
stuff he didn't say that was necessarily
good or bad this is what happened and he
wasn't like commenting on it but um oh
and I also want to say if you really
like Videodrome and want to see
something else in that line from
Cronenberg if you haven't seen it you
should probably see existence from 1999
which is I saw it when it came out and I
remember really digging it at the time I
don't think I've seen it since then but
it's kind of a similar theme to to
Videodrome and it should
noted to that all the movies that
Cronenberg did in between video German
existence were adaptations or he didn't
train in the screenplays but you know he
wrote Videodrome
and he wrote eXistenZ so it's almost
like they book ended cuz in between he
did like the dead zone which was a
Stephen King adaptation he did make it
lunch which was when Burroughs he did
crash which was JG Ballard and you know
all this other kind of stuff so also
have to mention Deborah Harry Deborah
Harry did a really good job she's right
and yeah her acting was really good and
it's surprising that we didn't see her
in anything else she didn't she was in
some John Waters movies I think if I
remember correctly Debbie Harry as I've
always loved Debbie Harry she is like
she's like so sexy and so cool and she's
like she was like the perfect yeah for
the talk
she was the perfect person for this role
yeah for that time she was totally
believable she is she look she looked
great
yeah she's gorgeous you're that's really
good really good and sometimes you see
her performing live in certain area
looks a little rough but in this picture
she looks very glamorous really good
liver yeah and you know she like like he
said it was kind of a shame she wasn't
in more movies I know she was she was on
movie but she wasn't anything like many
cool horror movies or you know I mean
not that I saw yeah I'm like I said I
know she was in some but I can't
remember I know she was in a couple John
Waters movies I want to say maybe she
was in cry-baby or serial mom I can't
remember I'm sorry baby had that porn
star
Tracy Laurie's heel or well yeah I know
she was a I don't think that Mary was in
that well that was it that was 1990
though so why is she might have been in
it is like someone's mom or something I
do that a long time either but um you
know like I said so you know probably
should see eXistenZ cuz like I said it
kind of explores the same it's it's
about virtual reality gaming and it's
[ __ ] like that so it's kind of the same
you know sort of thing and I definitely
have to see video yeah it's a classic
and like I said hated at the time it was
it was actually a financial bomb yeah at
the time
unlike scanners which was very
successful yeah didn't get it they they
they put it on cable though and it
became a late-night cable sensation
everyone remembers this movie so it's
almost a lot of other move
really did it was kind of one of those
kind of sleeper yeah movies where time
I'm sure it made money oh yeah it
probably did but like at the time it
really didn't so that'll probably do it
for this one I definitely want to do
another Cronenberg movie I want to do
Dead Ringers because that's my other
favorite one that do the brood and yeah
we got it probably gonna do it for it
too and they want the sex out these guys
do that one too shivers she ever saw
from within we just saw that recently
yeah that's the first time I've seen it
I liked it yeah you should probably he's
making a [ __ ] ton of movies and like I
said I'm looking at the list and I've
seen them all other than that one action
movie from it I've also got to give a
shout out to that criterion blu-ray it
was really nice really good got lots and
lots of extras and when you open it up
inside of it look at the case looks like
a beta man it looks like a Betamax with
like a hand draw like a handwritten
label on it yes this video drone this is
video drama that like it with somebody's
it's so right yeah and it has hours and
hours of extra stuff yeah there's a lot
of really cool extras on it it's really
really highly recommended now I did hear
that the British version the Aero
version actually has more extra [ __ ] on
it that's not on the criterion one but
they say the transfer is real similar
yeah but it's transfer similar so you
know it depends on what kind of extra
[ __ ] you want this this one I don't like
an arrow version Prabhas more yeah I
think it does have a lot it doesn't have
that cool box it didn't have that cool
yeah it didn't have the cool box it have
a cool cover but it doesn't have the
cool Betamax Bohol Betamax looking thing
with all the the test pattern lines and
stuff like that on it was really cool
but yeah definitely recommended if you
have not seen it like I said [ __ ] I
buy classic and certainly one of my
favorite Cronenberg movies and that'll
do it for this latest movie review
please remember to visit us on patreon
if you would and like share subscribe to
our channel and all that good stuff and
we'll be back with another movie review
as well as another episode very soon see
you later